oui on a toujours entendu des phrases
bateaux oui le foot n'est pas fait pour
les femmes
avec vous nous restons sous le signe du
charme et de vos footballeuses
françaises qui ont rencontré les
Norvégiennes
où elles sont et puis moi je voudrais
vous remonter ce soir je voudrais cette
misogynie parce que c'est complètement
ridicule on veut faire de la femme
sportive un sexe symbole on veut des
Catherine Deneuve des boderek et des
Ursula Andress sur tous les terrains du
monde
c'est fou quand même moi j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour ce genre de de femmes
qui qui se sont battus et les pionnières
ont été très importantes pour pour
l'évolution du foot de génération en
génération on se doit de continuer à se
battre pour pour les suivantes et c'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire tout
simplement